liebe Zuschauer bevor du die neueste
Folge der heute-show endlich wieder zum
gemeinsamen Fernsehvergnügen einlädt
noch ein kurzer wahrnhinweis die
folgende Sendung ist kein Bestandteil
der Fernsehgeschichte denn sie ist ja
noch gar nicht gelaufen für den Fall
dass Sie Passagen enthalten sollte die
Morgen als diskriminierend empfunden
werden bitten wir heute schon um
entschuldigung da sind nämlich Witze
dabei also unterste Schublade mein Tipp
schauen Sie stattdessen lieber alte
otto-shows in der DDR Mediathek
warte wie bitte die sind auch
diskriminieren doch gerade wohl nicht
wahr sein herzlich willkommen zur
heute-show schön dass Sie dabei sind ja
zurück aus der langsamer Pause und man
erkennt das Land kaum wieder
schwächelnde Wirtschaft und starke
Rechtspopulisten wissen Sie eigentlich
was das heißt Deutschland ist plötzlich
ein ganz normales EU-Land oh ja man
könnte auch sagen wir sind hart
aufgeschlagen auf dem Boden der
Realitäten
Olaf Scholz noch nicht beim Joggen
es steht ihm wirklich oder ich finde es
steht ihm endlich mal was los in seinem
Gesicht ja Olaf Scholz sie werden es
mitbekommen haben entdeckt die
Selbstironie und auch das Ausland ist
begeistert
ja komm alle doofen Piraten Witze sind
längst gemacht und ich sag mal so der
nächste der Captain Olaf auf kumex
anspricht wird Kiel geholt Freunde der
Wahl kämpft die MS Deutschland in
schwerer See laut IWF wachsen in diesem
Jahr sämtliche Industrienationen nur wir
nicht wir schrumpfen
ja ja hier neueste Schätzung neueste
Schätzung des ifo Instituts um 0,4 %
Zitat in nahezu allen Branchen steht die
Tendenz auf laute so aber jetzt jetzt
meine Damen und Herren drehen wir den
Eulen kann wieder auf Kurs und zwar mit
Olafs neuem Deutschland packt ja wie
erklärt man das es im Grunde eine Art
Pakt für Deutschland endlich heißt doch
Deutschland oder das sollten wir tun wir
sollten endlich ernst machen und der
Bundeskanzler hat ein kackt angekündigt
finde ich jetzt ein bisschen hart muss
ich sagen die Idee ist doch gut
verstehen sie Bund Länder und
Oppositionen gemeinsam für Deutschland
toll ich sag mal wenn sich jetzt noch
die Ampel selber mal auf irgendwas
eingehen kann wer soll uns dann noch
aufhalten hier Robert Habeck findet wie
immer die passende Metapher hat aber
wenn man hinten raus genau zuhört wenig
Ahnung von Fußball als
Wirtschaftsminister würde ich mir
wünschen dass wir
bei all den Herausforderungen die es
ohne Frage gibt sie mit einer Haltung
des wir werden dieses Spiel gewinnen
angehen und nicht mehr im Kopf in den
Sand auf Spielfeld laufen
mit dem Kopf im Sand laufen
woher kennt er denn Hansi Flix Plan für
die EM hier Deutschland auf dem
Economist Cover der kranke Mann Europas
ein Ampelmännchen am Tropf und da ist
leider was dran vor allem wegen der
hohen Energiekosten überlegen Sie mal
eine Firma in Frankreich zahlt für Strom
nur ein Drittel von dem was eine
deutsche Firma zahlt in den USA ist es
sogar nur ein Viertel wie geht's also
weiter mit dem Ampelmännchen ich sag mal
so wenn es blöd läuft verliert es
demnächst seinen Job in der
Chemieindustrie deshalb verlässt ihn
seine Ampel Frau er wird obdachlos und
drogensüchtig muss auf den Strich gehen
klar und wird am Ende von einem
chinesischen Auto überfahren ja die
Chinesen sind gerade die Stars auf der
Internationalen Automobilausstellung in
München in China haben sie auf dem
e-automat VW und Co sauber abgehängt
warum weil die deutschen Autobauer viel
zu lange gepennt haben bei
Batterietechnik und Software weil sie
weiter für ihre Männer kämpfen wie der
BMW-Chef diese Woche also Ampel Bashing
gut und schön aber vielleicht gibt es in
einigen deutschen Branchen auch ein
kleines managementproblem freundlich
formuliert
freundlich formuliert also was stimmt
Deutschland schiebt tatsächlich
gewaltige strukturelle Probleme vor sich
her über zehn merkeljahre Aufschwung mit
billigen Zinsen wurden verschenkt in
denen hätten wir unsere Infrastruktur
sanieren müssen und die Erneuerbaren
schneller ausbauen jetzt geht leider
beides nicht mehr ich glaube jeder von
ihnen kennt Geschichten oder musste es
schon erleben was passiert wenn eine
Brücke gesperrt werden muss ganz
abgesehen auch für Hindernisse der
Energiewende denn ich kann Ihnen sagen
die Windanlagen die wir gerne bauen
möchten kriegen wir teilweise nicht mehr
über die Brücken weil die
Schwerlasttransporte über diese Brücken
nicht mehr fahren dürfen
das ist also diese Brückentechnologie
von der jetzt immer alle reden verstehe
ja ja genau deshalb fordert das Institut
der deutschen Wirtschaft keine linke
Kaderschmiede in dem Sinne öffentliche
Investitionen zum Beispiel für
Infrastruktur von der Schuldenbremse
auszunehmen aber nicht mit Christian
Lindner der jongliert lieber hochseriös
mehrere schattenhaus eine
beziehungsweise Sondervermögen ja hat
sich doch bewährt Freunde natürlich ja
ich meine viele Ökonomen sagen
Schuldenbremse und gleichzeitig die
komplette deutsche Industrie auf Grün
stellen das wird so nicht klappen dann
müssen wir ran genau wie an den
Fachkräftemangel wo der eigentliche
Horror ja noch kommt in demnächst die
ganzen faulen bumer in Rente gehen ne
ich z.B ja ja wo sollen die ganzen
Fachkräfte dann herkommen und vor allem
warum sollten die ausgerechnet zu uns
wollen Robert Habeck lockt mit einem
Video Germany ist der country
happening right now aber
economyal digitalisation
[Musik]
Germany sagt er ohne rot zu werden es
ist doch Wahnsinn wirklich meine Werbung
lügt ja oft klar aber man kann es auch
übertreiben Freunde das geht doch auch
ehrlicher halb es ist Robert we have
leider leider approblem
made in china ist no better than made in
Germany you believe it not our last
Erfindung was when we change the
Autofenster Handkurbel Typ Knöpfe
energy from Putin in have only of
Exporte gesetzt das now in der es we are
loser ist egal wohin man guckt no
matters in running and jumping Soccer WM
out in the Vorrunde Deutschland
[Applaus]
das wäre ehrlicher
bringt ja nichts wenn wir die kommenden
Fachkräfte anlügen und dann sind die
enttäuscht wenn die hier sind also ich
sag mal Deutschland muss jetzt endlich
die großen Reformen hinter sich bringen
es hilft ja nichts und dass wir mal
weniger oder langsamer wachsen das ist
ja kein Grund so Panik manche tun ja so
als ob morgen die deutsche Industrie
stirbt und wir übermorgen alle wieder
vom Baum kacken ne so ist es ja auch
nicht der deutsche gruselt sich halt
gerne ist die die Lust am Untergang und
am Vermischen von Themen da ist es dann
wir haben das Gewinnen an sich verlernt
auch beim Sport okay Basketball können
wahrscheinlich
aber sonst die deutschen Frauen sind in
der WM Vorrunde rausgeflogen was für
eine Enttäuschung keine einzige Medaille
für das deutsche Team bei der
Leichtathletik Weltmeisterschaft das gab
es bislang noch nie warum sind wir so
verdammt schlecht
ist eine berechtigte Frage warum und
übrigens die Ursachen fürs deutsche
Leichtathletik debake sind komplex unter
anderem gab es da verletzungsbedingte
Absagen von Leistungsträgern oder ist
doch schon die geplante Reform der
Bundesjugendspiele schuld denn sie
werden es gelesen haben die sollen ja
umgewandelt werden in Bundesliga Spiele
und dann wundern wir uns über das
allgemeine ablosen in Sport und
Gesellschaft sagt zum Beispiel ernsthaft
also zumindest sinngemäß Christian
Lindner genau wie dieser Flagge
Sportlehrerin und Sprecherin der Aktion
finger weg von unseren bundesjugendspiel
ist die Debatte nicht ein bisschen sehr
konstruiert ja das kann man so sehen
wenn es ein scheiß egal ist dass dieses
Land immer
unglaublich was die Iren davor haben
Wettbewerb statt
tkampf Freude an der Bewegung soll im
Vordergrund stehen ich bin doch nicht
Sportlehrerin geworden und Kinder Freude
zu machen die sollen nachts schreiend
aufwachen und an mich denken
bei der Reform geht es nur um
Grundschulkinder die sind ja noch voll
klein ja eben der Wille des Kindes muss
möglichst früh gebrochen werden
Leistungsbereitschaft schon mal gehört
Friedrich Merz hat völlig Recht der
deutsche will nichts mehr leisten vier
Tage Woche Homeoffice und jetzt auch
noch Bundesjugendspiele bei denen keiner
mehr heult ja wo leben wir denn und das
sagt nicht nur Fritze märz das Sagen
führende intellektuelle
falsch wichtig ist Ansporn und auch
gerade derjenige vielleicht nicht gut
ist dann wird er halt im nächsten Jahr
gut
und wenn er dann immer noch schlecht ist
Händen wie ihn so lange bis er wieder
ins Bett macht anders geht's doch nicht
meine Fresse wir waren mal so gut gerade
im Osten das war noch gesundes fort
Förderung und damals hat auch noch
keiner über Sendern geredet
ja das stimmt ich verstehe die ganze
Aufregung nicht wir haben bei der
Basketball WM heute sensationell die
Amis im Halbfinale geschlagen oder hier
bei der Touren WM da hat die deutsche
Athletin neulich fünf Goldmedaillen
geholt in der rhythmischer
Sportgymnastik oh der feine Herr welke
liebt rhythmische Sportgymnastik lag die
da
da übrigens Freundchen ich habe aber bei
deiner alten Schule in Gütersloh
angerufen stellt sich raus der kleine
olli hat sich bei sieben
Bundesjugendspielen Folge krank gemeldet
ja aber das kann man erklären ich hatte
damals Reizdarm und meistens rund um die
Bundesjugendspiele
wahnsinnig ja deine Schule hat gesagt es
wird nachgeholt und zwar jetzt
bitte
scheiße
mein Gott wenn ich das schon sehe nur
Körperspannung wie so ein sackgulasch ja
ich habe eigentlich einen Test von
meinem Heilpraktiker
wie das geht 3 2 1 Los 100 Jahre her
unglaublich er stößt wie ein Mädchen
Mädchen sagt man nicht mehr das
sexistisch halt die Fresse
dieser Flagge
ja wirklich besser
umziehen so meine Damen und Herren heute
hat die Ampel endlich ihr Gebäude
Energiegesetz als schmerzhafte
zahngeburt auf die Welt gebracht
gequetscht also das was noch davon übrig
ist falls irgendwer noch durchsteigt was
geht also noch mit dieser Regierung
formulieren es fortschrittskoalition
große Frage ja ich schwöre das jetzt
wirklich der letzte Piraten Geld für
heute ja auf Schloss Meseberg dieser
ambulanten Tagesklinik für hoffnungslos
zerstrittene Koalition
haben sie immerhin Besserung gelobt
viele Reformen Prozesse endlich sind wir
die angegangen aber wir haben immer
schlecht übereinander geredet oder immer
wieder schlecht übereinander geredet und
das scheint so als könnte ich jetzt mal
aufhören
das wäre natürlich ein träumchen
wenn die ab jetzt regelrecht
zusammenarbeiten würden im Grunde fast
wie eine ja wie eine Regierung oder
übrigens nur einen Tag nur einen Tag
nach diesem harbex-statement hat die
FDP-Fraktion den Atomausstieg in Frage
gestellt genau weil Humor
19% der Deutschen sind noch zufrieden
mit der Arbeit der Ampel und ich hoffe
die sind alle in ärztlicher Behandlung
letzten Winter haben sie uns immer in
Form frieren gerettet das wird gerne
vergessen aktuell macht die Ampel
allerdings ein paar echt schlimme Fehler
ich sage nur Klima Geld fest versprochen
im Koalitionsvertrag fest versprochen so
zum ersten Januar wird der CO2-Preis
erhöht von 30 auf 40 € pro Tonne was zum
Beispiel tanken und heizen natürlich
teurer macht dafür sollte es eben diesen
Ausgleich geben das Klima Geld pro
Bürger für alle die gleiche Summe was
sozial gerecht ist weil viel Fahrer und
Vielflieger dann eben unterm Strich mehr
zahlen und jetzt ist das so der Teil mit
dem erhöhen der klappt wohl wie geplant
das mit dem uns was zurückgeben ja das
ist wir stellen uns das auch zu leicht
vor meine Damen und Herren das hat der
Christian doch schon letztes Jahr
erklärt dann muss nämlich beim beim bei
der Behörde die es macht eine
Entscheidung muss da noch getroffen
werden müssen Steuernummer und IBAN
zusammengebracht werden jetzt sind wir
aber ein paar deutsche also sind ein
paar IBAN die man einsammeln muss ja
klar natürlich ja natürlich
jeder der schon mal ibans einsammeln
musste
der weiß das ist eine sauerarbeit musst
du mit einer Schubkarre von Tür zu Tür
ne wenn die ibans mit der Steuernummer
zusammengelötet ist ein totaler Albtraum
tatsächlich könnte das Geld auch durch
die Rentenkassen die Jobcenter und die
Finanzämter ausgezahlt werden wenn es
denn politisch gewollt wäre vor einem
Jahr hat Linda noch gesagt in 18 Monaten
jetzt heißt es wohl Ende nächsten Jahres
wenn es klappt ein verheerendes Signal
wo doch sowieso immer weniger Leute Bock
auf konkreten Klimaschutz haben gibt es
denn anderswo schon Klima Geld bitte in
fucking Österreich die Regierung beginnt
heute mit der Auszahlung des heurigen
klimabonos je nach Wohnort bekommt man
zwischen 110 und 220 Euro
meine Damen und Herren ja Herr Gott
Sakra wirklich ja gut ich weiß gar nicht
kann man es vergleichen die Österreicher
haben natürlich auch weniger Heizkosten
weil ein Teil der Familie im Keller
wohnt aber trotzdem regt sein ja auf
das ist ja ärgerlich seit einem Jahr
kriegen die schon Klima Bonus wir gehen
mal auf die Webseite das glauben sie gar
nicht da steht dann warte mal was ist
der klimabonus eine Bonuszahlung aha wer
bekommt den klimabonus alle was muss man
dafür tun nichts und es gibt eine
kostenlose Hotline
und bei uns ist das Geld aus den
co2-einnahmen schon komplett für andere
Sachen verplant wirklich für neue
Wärmepumpen grün produzierten Stahl oder
die Ansiedlung von chip-fabriken toll
ach ja Österreicher müsste man sein das
heißt schon seit den 50ern
[Musik]
wir können uns den Ball locker leisten
aber Franz von welchem Geld
[Musik]
bekommen einfach so ich dachte das wäre
wahnsinnig kompliziert das muss absolut
nichts machen
die Piefke dein Berlin sind einfach
zum Scheißen
ich will doch selber deutsch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist wirklich ein Eigentor dass ich
die Ampel da schießt denn das mit den
höheren co2-preisen beim Tanken und
heizen trifft dann ja ab Januar vor
allem sozial schwächere Haushalte aber
Eigenheimbesitzer kriegen die Wärmepumpe
gefördert waren SPD und Grüne nicht mal
linke Parteien meine doch vom Bären
Dienst für den Klimaschutz mal ganz zu
schweigen Klimaschutz reden wir darüber
mit einem Mann der aus
nachhaltigkeitsgründen seit Jahrzehnten
denselben Pullunder Trick mit Olaf
Schuber Olaf schön dass du da bist
Klimaschutz gilt offenbar vielen Leuten
nur noch als lästige Zumutung als teure
Gängelung jetzt argumentieren manche es
ist zu viel amageddon so viel
Weltuntergang in der Debatte und ich
frag mich ja was wäre denn die
Alternative
was heißt Weltuntergang ich meine für
uns hier in der gemäßigten Zone läuft
der Klimawandel ja erstmal ganz komoot
oder Mitte September herrliche
kuscheltemperaturen also ich sitze heute
Abend noch nacktschaufen Balkon ja also
nicht nackt klar sondern im Bikini ähm
aber die Menschen jetzt immer nur zu
verängstigen ich glaube das ist ja auch
nicht die Lösung das sieht man ja bei
den Rauchern die haben ja immer die
diese Schockbilder drauf so was machen
die Raucher ja also ich sammle die ich
habe jetzt so ein Album so nikotini und
ähm habe ich eine Foto oder fast alle es
fehlt noch das Raucherbein das linke ähm
ja und ich meine du weißt ich habe ja
auch Kinder ja ich meine auf diesen
Zigarettenschachteln der steht immer
drauf rauchen macht unfruchtbar
ich hatte mich darauf verlassen ja
so und plötzlich dann so eine Explosion
in der Leistungskurse ja also das ist
halt ja die Grünen sind kann man sagen
inzwischen ganz offiziell der Buhmann in
den Umfragen und in den Bierzelten nur
noch mit den Aggressionen die die letzte
Generation abkriegt die haben übrigens
heute angekündigt dauerhafte Proteste ab
nächste Woche in Berlin wie beurteilst
du die ganze Kleberei ja die die hier
genau die Generation
ich finde diesen Namen ja wirklich
eigentlich passender denn ich meine
letzte Generation das ist eine kühne
These da muss man dann wirklich auch
aufpassen also ich meine muss man ja
dran bleiben also wenn einer aus dem
Verein schwanger wird ja dann heißt das
sofort Lügner also
naja und ich will das jetzt auch nicht
schlecht reden so aber sich da so fest
zu kleben
mir fehlt ein bisschen so der letzte bis
sage ich also meine jesus war da
konsequenter ja also
finde ich also wenn meine Kinder dort
mitmachen würden dann würde ich aber
sagen pass auf entweder richtig oder gar
nicht ja und glaube ich auch ein ganz
cooles Login wenn man sagen würde hier
Nägel mit Köpfchen ja
genau heute ist ja das Gebäude
Energiegesetz dann endlich mal durch den
Bundestag gegangen wie heißt du selber
in welchen anderen Bereichen versuchst
du ein bisschen Klima neutraler zu leben
hast du ein Auto z.B ein Auto ähm
habe ich ja also unter anderem ähm muss
aber deswegen ich bin heute hier zum
Beispiel Klima neutral angereist mit dem
Fahrrad im Gegensatz zu dir also vom
Hotel mit dem Fahrrad natürlich erstmal
ins Hotel klar im Taxi vom Flughafen ähm
und klar setzt ein Umdenken ein in
vielen Bereichen beim Heizen hat sich
wirklich einiges verändert also ich habe
da wirklich wie soll ich sagen im
Schnitt gemacht ich habe das letzte Mal
geheizt habe ich im März
und ich glaube ich bin mit dem Thema
durch und auch hier natürlich versuche
ich irgendwie also ich weiß nicht ob man
es merkt aber meine Gags sind wirklich
alle recycelt und ähm
zweitverwertet aber ich muss ehrlich
sagen also Klimaschutz wäre für mich
noch noch wirklich wesentlich
attraktiver wenn ich wüsste ich muss
nicht mitmachen ja und ich glaube so
geht's ja den meisten ja und deshalb
wenn ich wirklich besser wenn man also
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen immer zuerst von
den anderen Fotos ne ich meine es gibt
doch genug andere denken darüber
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
wir haben gesagt die soll man den
Lieblingswitz erzählen was mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Bezos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper aboniert endlich denn
verkackten heute schon Kanal also geht
doch